what do you have to do for yourself oh
where you going pot there's so many
oranges which fruit is him come on
my clothes are you an orange tell me if
your fruit this orange is very
suspicious god damn it what
hello how we're here we can squish them
we can squish them the squish only
oranges okay and then he have nowhere to
hide oh my god you can squeeze you wait
I'm pretty close to the steps I just
hear orange splatter everywhere cut oh
good Oh what I just got molested by an
orange thank you where I come here what
do you help you got oh great now I [ __ ]
vitamin C hooray let's kill the fall did
you kill him is he dead
thank God I'm alright aren't you glad
I've got grenades
hahaha I wasn't quite prepared for how
many [ __ ] oranges they were gonna be
I thought you're all kidding I thought
it was like a little batch of them this
is just thinks is really high oh my god
you're giving birth to an orange
oh hey that's good orange guys there's
not an orange what are you talking about
what are you talking about
I want one of my five a day and you've
gotta be it Oh No Oh Ron this is the
best party I know but it's my friend
what's happening hey how's it going no I
can't go in minks help I don't fit in I
don't know why all right I've got a
change [ __ ] you the orange smell I'm
gonna kill you in a second come here
where did you hide minks what are you
doing [ __ ] [ __ ] no no
got if I'm gonna haul them tight without
offense
um can see here's an offense pens or
whatever that is in plain sight boom
breaker
I reckon arm is in orange yeah it
wouldn't make sense if you see me on the
fence then yours ok cool that's awesome
what what what do you have to defend say
for yourself oh where you going pot what
all right I had to grenade all the
oranges well I'm gonna leave you guys a
present when you wake up from whatever
you're doing right now right in front of
me you'll have one nice little gift I've
got a leaning tower of paint pots in
front of me when I come around I'm not
gonna be happy okay that's all the
present you're getting okay I'm excited
actually
hey orange vomit is kind of underrated
oh [ __ ] yeah you do ng [ __ ]
it's a Oh what do you do that oh no yes
no yes Oh what was that
I saw pasta Hemmings how you doing oh oh
yeah it's hunting time now I I suspect
and present otherwise I'll be
disappointed a lot
yeah we like I want to face I want
PewDiePie face made out of oranges on
the floor [ __ ] what am I doing here
wait no I just remember there was two of
those that's a pretty good hiding spot
um hey what what get owned okay I have
the ultimate tactic makes now what are
you doing now don't break it now what
did you took it away from me I'll think
okay how how dare you I'm on the back
and I mean now not there anymore
silly oh my god they're not on the
balcony damn it I was on the balcony on
I was literally right next to you I just
wanted to like emoji them somehow 360
nice hello
yes I did I don't believe it
I was gonna do like a my grenade all
right looking the other way oh [ __ ]
we must get him I've seen other things
moving them up and think that oh hello
there little cup oh good to meet you
come here [ __ ] come on stop chatting
[ __ ]
gonna [ __ ] Cali are you [ __ ] back
yeah you think you can play us huh
buckets
Neph today we're fine you're sliding
over my face
oh you're welcome yeah be cool be cool
every man for himself yeah I'm sorry
minx you had to be sacrifice for the
greater good of the team don't worry
about it don't worry don't worry
I don't worry about they'll never see me
I don't know it's so weird
minx we're a way oh hey hey ba ba ba ba
ba danke I was in here too
can we like cause an earthquake if we
jump enough how about the other door oh
[ __ ]
Rebecca don't grenade very Kate didn't
work out Bravo what are you
robber I'm just gonna turn around and if
someone happen to stab me in the back